Transcription: Stephen Amany
Relecteur: Samira Kwache
Bonsoir à tous et à toutes.
Visualiser sa réussite.
Je vous avoue que quand on m’a donné
le thème de la soirée,
j’ai trouvé ça très bizarre.
Personnellement, je n’ai jamais
visualisé ma réussite.
Puis d’ailleurs, on peut même
se poser la question de...
Qu’est-ce-que la réussite ?
Je suis sûre que si je demande
à chacun d’entre vous dans la salle,
aucun d’entre nous
n’aura la même définition.
Moi, quand je pense à la réussite,
la première chose qui me vient à l’esprit
c’est déjà qu’il y a deux catégories,
deux types de profils
face à cette réussite.
Il y a un tout petit noyau
de personnes très chanceuses
qui ont la chance dès l’enfance
de savoir où elles vont,
de savoir ce qu’elles veulent faire
et elles déroulent au cours de leur vie.
Elles veulent être pompier,
médecin, enseignant, astronaute,
beaucoup de Thomas Pesquet
ou autre chose.
Et il y a la vaste majorité des gens
dans laquelle je me mettrais.
Qui ne sait pas, en fait.
Et pour lesquels la réussite
reste un terme un peu flou.
Et ça s’éclaircit, on va dire
au fur et à mesure
du parcours de vie.
Donc moi, c’est clairement
à cette catégorie que j’appartiens.
Et si je devais dire quelque chose,
si j’ai envie de parler
de quelque chose avec vous ce soir,
ce serait peut-être
plus de peur que de visualisation.
La peur, les peurs que j’ai pu avoir
tout au long de mon parcours
c’est la raison de ma présence,
ici, aujourd’hui.
Peur du conformisme.
Peur de louper quelque chose.
Peur de passer à côté de sa vie.
Peur de se tromper. Peur de l’échec.
On peut en citer beaucoup.
Alors, je vais vous proposer
un petit voyage
sur le long de mes peurs,
le long de mon parcours
pour tenter de vous expliquer
comment et pourquoi j’ai fait de ces peurs
une force pour me créer
un chemin vers la réussite.
Alors, je vous emmène,
tout d’abord, en 2009.
Donc comme la majorité de la salle,
je suis étudiante, élève et ingénieure.
Et c’est le moment de choisir
où je vais passer
ma dernière année d’études.
Et là, vous me direz, c’est pas forcément
le choix le plus effrayant
Où aller étudier, quel pays découvrir.
Mais en fait, ça me fait peur
parce que quand j’échange avec
mes camarades de classe, ma famille,
mes professeurs, je me rends compte
que l’idée qu’ils ont de l’échange parfait
ne correspond absolument pas
à celui que moi je peux avoir.
Moi, je rêve...
J’ai un rêve de petite fille,
c’est découvrir le Brésil
et plus particulièrement Rio.
Je vois que l’échange est disponible.
Je me dis « That’s for me! »
Et en même temps,
c’est très loin des attentes
de tout mon écosystème.
On s’attendait à ce que j’aille
dans une école plus cotée
et que je suive mes petits camarades.
Et j’ai peur...
J’ai peur tout simplement
de passer à côté d’une expérience
que je ne pourrais
peut-être plus jamais revivre
si je ne le fais pas à cet instant-là.
Et donc je vais faire le choix
de m’écouter et de partir dans une ville
où je ne parle pas la langue,
où je connais personne,
qui est réputée dangereuse.
Et vraisemblablement,
l’école n’est pas si bien cotée que ça.
Et 12 ans plus tard, aucun regret
parce que, comme
je me l’étais dit à 20 ans,
je n’y suis pas retournée depuis.
J’espère un jour.
J'ai appris énormément de choses.
Bon, vous vous en doutez,
j’ai pu faire la fête,
j’ai pu voyager, j’ai pu faire
tout un tas de choses.
Mais j’ai surtout appris au Brésil
qu’il est important de m’écouter,
d’écouter mes peurs,
d’écouter mes ressentis
pour me créer de nouvelles opportunités.
Et c’est un outil
qui m’a beaucoup servi
tout au long de ma carrière et même
dans ma vie perso et ce qui a suivi.
Je vous fais un petit flashforward.
On est en 2014, donc j’ai été diplômée,
j’habite à New York,
je travaille en finance de marché.
Alors, quand on parle de New York,
je pense que pour beaucoup dans la salle
c’est une ville qui fait rêver,
la ville monde,
des gens qui viennent de partout,
des opportunités,
une ville gigantesque,
une ouverture sur le monde.
C'est comme ça que je le voyais.
La ville de l’ambition,
la ville où tout est possible.
Et New York, pour moi,
ça n’a absolument pas été ça.
Ça a été la ville où j’ai découvert
ce qu’était le harcèlement moral.
Alors pas à titre personnel
mais dans le cadre de mon travail.
Je me suis retrouvée dans un poste où
je voyais mes collègues autour de moi
plus âgés, plus seniors,
qui, pour la plupart,
avait des responsabilités,
une femme,
un mari,
des enfants,
un prêt sur le dos,
et qui supportait l’insupportable
Un patron odieux,
des ordres contradictoires en permanence,
du micro-management.
Enfin, Infrarouge sur France 2
en direct devant mes yeux.
Et ça m’a fait très peur encore une fois.
La première peur que j’ai eue,
c’est tout simplement de perdre mon temps.
La deuxième peur, la  plus intense,
et qui m’a fait réfléchir,
ça a été de me dire
que peut-être dans 20 ans,
ce sera ma vie.
Peut-être que j’aurai
la malchance de tomber
sur une version de mon boss actuel
et que j’aurai des responsabilités,
je pourrai pas me permettre
de faire un jump.
Et cette peur a été le début
d’une introspection.
Comme j’aime les voyages,
j’ai pris mon petit sac à dos,
je suis partie dans l’Ouest américain
et j’y ai réfléchi.
Pour la première fois de ma vie...
- parce que j’ai eu la chance
de faire un parcours qui était tracé
où j’ai trouvé un boulot,
où au final, je n’ai pas eu
à me poser de questions. -
Pour la première fois de ma vie,
je me suis demandée
ce que j’avais envie de faire,
où j’avais envie d’être.
Et j’ai commencé à réfléchir petit à petit
sur ce qu’était la réussite pour moi.
Alors pour moi, la réussite,
c’était être libre, quelque part.
Être heureuse de se lever tous les matins,
apprendre encore et toujours
et avoir une stimulation,
ne pas être dans un environnement toxique.
Donc de ces réflexions commençaient
à se dessiner un plan.
Je suis ingénieure de formation,
donc quand on parle de plan,
j’aime bien que ce soit carré,
qu’il y ait un début et une fin,
que je puisse avoir une timeline.
Toutes ces réflexions m’ont fait dire
que j’avais besoin d’une nouvelle aventure
- une aventure entrepreneuriale,
sur ce coup -
mais en bon ingénieure,
je ne vais pas non plus
me lancer à l’aventure
sans savoir où je vais atterrir.
Donc, sur mon plan,
la première chose
que je me suis dite, au final,
c’est que je devais
me lancer dans le digital.
Pourquoi ?
Juste parce que j’ai fait
une école d’ingénieur,
notamment en informatique, pas uniquement
mais ca me paraissait une reconversion
plus accessible que d’autres
La deuxième chose que je me suis dite
c’est que je devais choisir un secteur
qui était très peu digitalisé
parce qu’on est 2015,
la start-up Nation
n’est pas encore ce qu’elle est
mais il y a déjà
une French Tech bien constituée.
Il y a beaucoup de talents,
beaucoup d’acteurs qui créent des choses.
Je n’ai pas la prétention
de révolutionner le monde.
J’ai juste la prétention de créer un
produit, de résoudre un problème
et de le faire de manière efficace.
Donc pour toutes ces raisons,
je commence à penser BTP
mais je n’ai pas fait d’études dans le BTP
je n’ai pas de réseau dans le BTP
Bien qu’ayant des idées,
je n’étais pas sûre de moi.
Absolument pas.
Et donc là, la peur m’a reprise,
une peur différente, ce coup-ci.
Peur de perdre son temps, encore une fois,
peur de ne jamais voir éclore le projet,
ou peur de totalement faire fausse route.
Et donc là,  on est en 2016,
je décide de rentrer en France
et bien que parlant autour de moi
de ce projet en continu
et ayant des retours qui étaient positifs
que ce soit de ma famille, de mes amis,
de mon entourage en général,
j’ai peur. Je me dis, au final,
les gens de mon entourage
ne connaissent pas forcément ce secteur.
Et puis ils me connaissent,
ils m’aiment, à priori, donc
ils ne sont pas forcément
totalement rationnels
par rapport a ce qu’ils me disent.
Donc j’ai besoin, en fait très vite,
d’aller confronter mon idée à un marché,
à des gens inconnus qui ne me doivent rien
et qui,  s’ils doivent me la détruire,
me la détruiront vite et efficacement
de manière que
je ne perde pas trop de temps.
Et donc, je vais à un Start-up Weekend.
Pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce que c’est,
un Start-up Weekend,
c’est tout simplement un weekend
où des porteurs de projet
présentent leur idée
devant un panel de professionnels,
d’investisseurs et de participants.
Donc j’y vais avec mon idée,
je la présente
et la première personne
avec laquelle je vais échanger ce soir-là
s’appelle Idir Ait Ahmed
Ça tombe bien, il est ingénieur
diplômé de l’ESTP,
spécialisé dans le BTP Travaux publics
et il me démonte mon idée.
Il me la détruit totalement
mais avec des arguments logiques.
Donc j’entends que je fais fausse route,
que certainement je vais perdre mon temps
et que la proposition de valeur
que je pensais être extraordinaire
n’a pas de viabilité sur ce secteur-là.
Et plus je parle avec lui,
plus je me rends compte
que la façon dont je prends
ses critiques, cet échec,
lui plaît.
Et il commence à me parler de son projet
parce qu’il dit qu’il est là
en tant que participant
mais il est aussi là
en « casting sauvage »
à la recherche d’un ou d’une associé.e
pour prendre le poste de CTO
sur sa start-up Tractor.
Alors CTO, pour ceux qui
ne savent pas ce que c’est,
c’est directrice technique,
« Chief Technical Officer »
C’est la personne,
qui, dans une start-up tech,
va, au tout début,
créer les outils technologiques,
faire grandir l’équipe et s’occuper
de toute la stratégie associée.
Et son idée à Idir, elle est naissante.
l n’y a pas encore de site,
ils sont deux,
ils se sont mis
à plein temps sur le projet,
il n’y a même pas un mois
et il y croit dur comme fer.
Tractor se veut
le Airbnb des engins de chantier,
une Marketplace de location
d’engins de chantier
entre professionnels.
Et bien que n’étant pas du secteur,
en parlant avec ce garçon
et en parlant ensuite avec Julien,
son associé,
je me dis qu’ils tiennent quelque chose
et j’y crois aussi.
Et donc c’est comme ça
que je vais devenir entrepreneure.
Parce qu’à un moment, j’ai eu peur
que cette peur,
j’ai cherché à la surmonter
et que le long du chemin,
j’ai rencontré des associés.
C’est comme ça que je démarre Tractor
avec deux associés
qui sont tous les deux ingénieurs
avec des spécialités différentes
et très vite on se dispatche les tâches.
Mais on a la lucidité de se dire très vite
qu’on ne sait pas tout
et de nombreuses peurs
surviennent à ce moment-là.
La peur de faire fausse route,
la peur d’avoir un produit
qui ne correspond
pas aux attentes du marché,
la peur d’être arrivé trop tôt
ou trop tard,
la peur de ne pas trouver sa clientèle...
Elles sont multiples.
et pour la première fois de ma vie,
je partage ces peurs avec mes associés
et ça fait la différence
parce qu’on en discute.
On en discute beaucoup
et on se dit assez vite
que ce qui nous manque,
tout simplement,
c’est les lumières de gens plus éclairés.
Donc, on va prendre des résolutions
face à ces problématiques sur lesquelles
on n’a pas d’expertise,
on n’a pas de solutions
Et ça va prendre plusieurs formes.
On va commencer tout simplement
par se rapprocher
d’un certain nombre
de réseaux entrepreneuriaux,
typiquement réseaux à entreprendre
pour trouver des mentors
qui sont eux-mêmes des entrepreneurs avec
plus de bagage que nous, plus d’expérience
plus de recul et qui vont
nous faire gagner du temps,
éviter des pièges
et surtout nous faire grandir
sur ce que c’est que structurer une boîte.
On va aussi se créer ce qu’on a appelé
« le conseil des sages »
qui est un assemblage
de plein de professionnels
qu’on est allé alpaguer au culot
sur LinkedIn
sur des expertises que nous n’avions pas,
et qu’on va réunir de temps en temps
ou voir en one-to-one
de manière à apprendre plus
sur ces sujets et ils sont nombreux.
Il y a le marketing, les opérations,
tout ce qui est RH, les finances.
Il y a beaucoup, beaucoup de thématiques
sur lesquelles on n’est pas calé à 100%.
Et ça va aussi nous faire grandir
très vite et ça va nous éviter
de tomber dans un bon nombre de pièges
que d’autres start-ups rencontrent
ou même pas forcément des start-ups,
tout type d’entrepreneurs.
La plus grande peur,
par contre, qu’on avait,
ça restait quand même cette peur
de ne pas avoir le bon produit,
de ne pas avoir la solution
qui correspondait à notre clientèle.
Et donc pour se rassurer,
très vite on a cherché
à aller trouver les retours de nos clients
par différents biais.
Et on a bien fait parce qu’en fait,
le produit qu’on avait imaginé,
le Airbnb des engins de chantier
qui m’a été vendu
ce n’est pas ce que
recherchait notre clientèle.
Alors moi, côté tech, clairement,
ça n’arrangeait pas mes affaires.
mais on a fait évoluer le produit
et petit à petit, de Airbnb,
on s’est rapproché
d’un modèle à la Booking.
Aujourd’hui, Tractor,
c’est un guichet unique
qui permet à des milliers
de professionnels partout en France
de louer tout type d’engins de chantier.
Et ça s’est fait parce qu’on a bossé
mais aussi parce qu’on a écouté ses peurs
et qu’on a cherché à trouver
un moyen de passer outre.
Alors là, je vous ai parlé des peurs
qu’on a eues en commun avec mes associés
mais moi, en tant qu’individu,
en tant que CTO, fraîche CTO,
j’avais des peurs personnelles aussi
sur lesquelles il a fallu travailler.
La peur déjà d’être
illégitime sur mon poste.
Alors oui, j’ai fait une école
d’ingénieur en informatique
mais je bossais
en finance de marché avant
- aucun rapport avec la tractopelle,
aucun rapport avec le web. -
Donc très vite,
de la même façon qu’on est allé
chercher des mentors en collectif
je vais faire la même chose
mais individuellement.
Je vais me rapprocher de ma communauté,
celle des développeurs.
Je vais aller chercher de l’info,
chercher des mentors
pour qu’ils me fassent grandir
et me permettent de sortir un produit
qui d’entrée de jeu, sera robuste
et tiendra la route sur le futur.
Ils vont m’aider à grandir, m’aider
à me positionner sur mes deux pieds
et à avoir confiance en moi,
tout simplement.
J’ai aussi eu peur parce que CTO,
il n’y a pas beaucoup de femmes, déjà,
encore moins de femmes noires,
encore moins de femmes noires ingénieures,
encore moins de femmes noires
ingénieures dans le BTP.
Donc, ça commençait à faire beaucoup.
Il manquait quelque petites choses
et j’aurais coché toutes les cases.
Mais bref, ça commençait à faire beaucoup
et je m’attendais
à un accueil plutôt froid de l’écosystème.
Ça me faisait peur mais j’avais besoin
de grandir, de développer une expertise
donc je suis allée voir mes pairs
et très vite, je me suis rendu compte
que ce que je pensais être un désavantage,
c’était un gros avantage
parce qu’en vrai,
quand il n’y en a pas beaucoup
on sort du lot beaucoup plus facilement.
C'est un argument marketing de folie,
on va pas se mentir.
Et ça m’a permis d’ouvrir des portes
qui, je pense, restent fermées
à bon nombre de gens
qui se lancent comme moi
sur ce type d’aventure.
Alors voilà,
je voulais vous parler de tout ça,
des peurs que j’ai eu,
du travail que j’ai fait sur moi
pour surmonter ces peurs.
Et s’il y avait qu’une seule chose,
pour moi, à retenir de mes propos ce soir
et un conseil à vous donner,
c’est de ne pas forcément
visualiser la réussite
mais plutôt d’essayer de visualiser
ce que représente l’échec pour vous.
Une fois que vous avez visualisé ça,
essayez de tout faire
pour vous en éloigner le plus possible.
Et je pense que vous vous rapprocherez,
si ce n’est pas déjà fait,
de la définition de ce que représente
la réussite pour vous.
Merci.